hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're gonna be
going over a famous game called the
evergreen game it was played between
anderson and gene Dufresne it was played
in the 1800's Anderson being probably
the top player around the 1850s and gene
Dufresne a very talented player in his
own right actually a student of Andersen
so it's always interesting to see a
student play the teacher why it's gonna
be played by Andersen and blacks gonna
be played by Dufresne now this was a
friendly this was not a tournament by
any means which I think actually added
some flavor to it because both sides
played an extremely extremely fun game
to watch so definitely gonna be
entertaining watching these two
powerhouses from a few hundred years ago
actually play chess and play a beautiful
game at that so the game started out
Anderson opted for the Evans gambit
which is we kind of come through medics
Bishop here to c4 and then when the
bishop is met here on c5 White's gonna
actually give up material here on b4 and
exchange for a lead in development so
when the bishop comes back here the
pawns gonna push forward to d4 and then
after we take here White's going to
castle on the kingside can't take right
away with this pawn simply because the
pawn is being pinned down to the King
right here
Black has a few options one of the more
common moves would just be to actually
take this pawn here on c3 in this
particular game black chose to play pawn
to d3 pushing this pawn a little bit
forward
white does have the option to go ahead
and retake if he wants to instead white
decides to go ahead and play very
aggressive and he actually brings this
Queen over here to b3 which attacks this
pawn here on b7 and if this bishop ever
gets involved into the game we could see
pawn to d6 then we could see the lights
where Bishop involved would be attacking
this pawn as well but very importantly
it's putting two attackers against this
very weakened square for black early on
the f7 squared
very early on weak for black because the
King is the only piece that defends this
and so it becomes a huge target early on
for white to attack so bring the Queen
here definitely an aggressive move here
from white and now the Queen is going to
come to f6 this kind of blocks it off it
also gets a queen involved into the game
you usually don't see nowadays which is
why sometimes I like to actually explore
some older games because people were
just relentless they would bring their
Queens out early they would do a lot of
stuff but nowadays it's kind of frowned
upon but it did make for some really
entertaining chess so bringing the Queen
out here to f6 to not only develop one
of the major pieces in the game but also
again very important to protect the
square here on f7 why it's gonna push
forward with this pawn pawns are
definitely meant to be pushed now there
are two attackers on this we have the
night here on c6 the Queen here on f6
but remember if you know we would have
the knight take and then the knight take
if the Queen were to take here then the
pawn here on f7 would be vulnerable so
although there are two attackers and
only one defenders black still has to
stay in check here no pun intended to
worry about this attack here on f7 black
now moves Queen to g6 doing a couple
things still being active in a game
protecting this pawn on f7 and also
protecting the pawn here on d3 Flex
might eventually just give this pawn
back in material again black is up in
material right now because you know why
played the Evans gambit but it does make
it a little bit harder white can't just
immediately take this pawn back with his
bishop so again it's kind of frustrating
right now but white does have some
options decides to play rook over here
to e1 could later play rook here to e3
put a double attacker on that pawn on d3
just one of the options that he does
have now the knight comes over here to
e7 which again is very good move you
would like to play you know Knight here
to f6 really get involved into the
center of the board but because that
pawn there on e5 that's kind of a pain
but this allows black to go ahead and
cast on the King side put another
defender on this f7 square with the rook
over here and on f8 so a lot of good
things that black has going form doesn't
have to worry about too much he does
have some King safety right now kind of
with this block off
why decides to go and play Bishop to a3
which right now is not doing too much
mostly as we just talked about this
Knight is now kind of blocking this off
even with the exchange you know a black
should probably go ahead and castle on
the Kings side and then even if there
was an exchange this is gonna be fine
for black is you know it's kind of an
open board right now give taking one of
the powerful bishops that white has off
the board it would be good in the
particular game though black chose to
play pawn to be fun kind of a question
move giving back some material but the
game that he gets isn't really that
significant so after the Queen takes the
rooks gonna swing over here to b8 so
black gets a small tempo gain here
getting his rook involved controlling
this long file right here on the B file
and again forcing this Queen to move so
the Queen doesn't have too many options
Queen does decide to come back here to
a4 and then we have the bishop swing
back to to b6 now keep in mind in this
particular situation black can no longer
castle on the King side if he does then
this night here on c6 is actually now
overloaded so if the bishop takes here
on e7 and then the knight takes then the
Queen can now take this Bishop on a5
which was a little bit different if we
come back and look at the original
position with the Queen here on b3 black
really doesn't have to worry about that
he can go ahead and castle on the King
side and he's gonna be completely safe
but after the you know the pawn comes
down to b5 and after the exchange the
Queen comes back here black and no
longer Castle so he needs to figure out
a way to either a have this bishop not
under attack or he also needs to find a
way to not have this piece overloaded if
you're white you always want to attack
the overloaded piece or take one of the
options away so you would want to attack
either this night or this Bishop because
this night here on c6 cannot defend both
of them so if you're just kind of
looking at strategies about both sides
are looking to do or what sides are
trying to prevent the other colors to do
that's kind of what both sides are
looking at with this Knight here on C
sit now we have the bishop coming back
here to b6 which makes sense we want to
make sure this night here on c6 is no
longer overloaded and then the Knights
gonna come here to d2 it's about time
that white finishes his development so
both of his rooks are connected now he
can get his rook over-involved into the
game on b1 try to counter-attack and
control the B file also has both of his
rooks here so we could also bring his
rook over here to d1 if he wanted to
control this semi-open file definitely
gives white some options he can also now
bring his Knight to e4 try to control
the stare of the board he doesn't have
the availability to bring his Knight to
c3 so really Knight to the two is his
only option now black plays Bishop here
to b7 which in my opinion is just a move
that you can't make it's not really
doing anything for black black really
has to castle on the King side again he
played bishop here to b6 to make sure
that his pieces weren't overloaded so
the could castle annie plays bishop here
to b7 not super important for his bishop
to come here to b7 it's not doing too
much in the game but again this puts
your game that's what Gina sided to play
now White's gonna bring his Knight to e4
which is an interesting move again it
develops one of his pieces to a central
square but it blocks off the Queen from
the pawn here on b3 which again black
kind of wanted to do now black has a few
options one move I really like for black
is the desperado move if we look at it
white on his next move can take this
pawn here on d3 that's fun the bishop
here on c4 is no longer really a huge
threat on this long diagonal so you know
taking here on d3 isn't gonna be too bad
it also has a discovered attack on the
Queen so if the knight were to move the
bishop would be attacking the bishop or
the Queen here on g6
so that would actually be completely
fine for white a really good move that
black has is desperado meaning that he
knows this pawns gonna leave by the
wayside it's gone has no chance at life
to actually play something pawn there to
d2 nice little move knowing that your
pawn or your piece is gonna go down in
flames and forcing your opponent in a
worse
or to take some additional material is
always good so in this petite case why
it has to do something he's not gonna
play you know the rook over here to be
one that ways to move right there if he
wants to take he's gonna take it with
the one of his knights and that's gonna
again kind of lose a tempo in the game
which is exactly what black wants so
this would have been good in the actual
game black decided to play Queen to f5
which is a pretty poor move because
after the bishop on d3 now Queen on F
sit on f5 has to move because the threat
of the knight coming here to f6 the
knight coming here to d6 both of these
are discovered attacks checking the King
here on the 8th but then also opening up
the door for the bishop to take the
Queen here on f5 so the Queen's forced
to move the Queen moves over here to h5
and then from here white decided to play
when I'm gonna consider a pretty crazy
move and he played Knight here to f6 now
part of me feels like if this was an
actual tournament or if maybe he was
playing Paul Morphy back in the day you
might not see him move like Knight to f6
you could see Knight to g3 again why it
has all the momentum he's definitely
leading in the game right now all of his
pieces are very active black really
doesn't have a lot of his pieces aligned
he hasn't castled so he doesn't have a
lot of kingside safety his one rook
that's controlling this file is blocked
by his own pieces his bishops really
aren't aren't doing too much this Bishop
here on b6 is somewhat active but his
Knights are both pretty passive you know
Knight here to g3 kind of opening up the
door for the Queen to move once again he
can now get his other dark squared
Bishop involvement at the game putting a
lot of pressure against wing as Queen
over definitely gonna be good for white
fortunately for us since we are going
back and looking at it he played Knight
here to f6 and I think back in probably
1850 he he had the choice he can either
take the safe route and play Knight here
to g3 or you could play Knight here to
f6 the worst that would happen is he
would have
you know an equal position that he was
maybe a little bit stronger than his
opponent and that he could probably win
in the end game but if his plan actually
worked out then 160 years later maybe
someone on YouTube would do some
commentary on the game that's at least
what I think he was thinking about back
in 1950 but alas here we are he plays
nine here to f6 pretty crazy move to go
ahead and sacrifice after the pawn takes
and the pawn recaptures we look at this
position things have definitely changed
we have a pawn here on f6 which is gonna
be a menace for black to deal with but
black can now he could bring his rook
over here to g8 he now controls this
long semi file right here semi open file
which is gonna be a pain for white
because that's where White's king is the
Queen can also come down to h3 after the
rooks over here putting a lot of
pressure on white white would be forced
you know bring his Bishop over here to
f1 to protect that Square bringing a lot
of the pieces that are active and making
them less active so again both sides now
have a lot of fighting chances this is
pretty close to equal as far as what's
gonna happen here black decided to go
ahead and bring his rook over here to g8
also again this night here on e7 can't
go anywhere it's being pinned down by
this rook on a1 if anyone was wondering
why this rook just doesn't or this
knight doesn't move here on e7 and now
the rook swings over here to d1 which
again we're just kind of getting into
these crazy moves because it makes a lot
of sense to go ahead and take this pawn
here on e7 or start to try to defend
over here on the King side and then
black has two options probably the best
move for black is to go ahead and play
Queen to h3 this forces white to go
ahead and do something right away
because the next move from black if
white ever blinks is checkmate right
here this is really really difficult for
white to to deal with in the actual game
again lucky for us it's always good to
look back black decided to play the
Queen over here to f3
and this actually opens up the door for
white to go on a crazy attack which is
exactly what he does this pawn here on
d7 is no longer being protected by the
Queen over here on h3 which is very
important because of the next line of
attacks that Anderson employs on the
game so we have the rook taking here on
e7 check and then we have the knight
coming back here on e7 taking and this
Knights no longer being pinned by the
rook on e1 so we can now move and again
this Queen not being over here on h3
protecting this pawn on d7 is actually
going to play a huge role in this next
sequence because the next weakens is
Queen over here to d7 and this is
probably the decoy of the century if if
you can ever employ a decoy like this in
a sacrifice like this it's just the
greatest feeling ever
I'm sure Anderson this particular case
was just like yep someone on YouTube is
gonna be making a video about me in a
160 years I actually pulled it off my
opponent had no clue this is what's
gonna happen this is really really
really awesome so after the king takes
then we had the bishop coming here to f5
a double check so both the rook and the
bishop are attacking double checks are
always good because they force your
opponent to move the King there's no
other way to stop at the King has to
move the King now moves back to e8 again
if there's other moves that he wanted to
try again he's gonna be checkmated
earlier and so the King comes back here
to e8 and then we had the bishop coming
here to d7 and the King comes back over
here to f8 again he could try other
moves but he's just gonna die just as
fast
you know if the King came over here to
the 8th then we're just gonna see the
bishop come here - to e7 again all these
moves could go other ways but it's still
gonna be the same result so the King
came over here to f8 and then the bishop
here on e7 checkmate
phenomenal game from Anders
and really really just crazy the fact
that he thought about this even when he
was sacrificing his night here on f6
also really glad that's you know gene
decided to take here on f3 and that come
down here on h3 but you know he probably
just didn't see the fact that two moves
after that the Queen was gonna have a
decoy on here on these seven so again
this was the Evergreen game really
really interesting to see you know some
of the powerhouses back in the game
completely just going at each other
sacrificing pieces left and right just
for these small advantages and then
eventually with one of the the greater
lines that you'll see at the end of the
game with some crazy sacrifices leading
into a double check and then eventually
a checkmate so hopefully you guys enjoy
this always wat like doing commentary on
old games just because they are super
super exciting so hopefully you enjoyed
hopefully you maybe learn something and
I'll see y'all in the next video thanks
for watching